P - Merry Christ-
Merry christ--
P - Oh you're here
Oh you're here
M - Oh you noticed quickly today
M -Thank you.
P - Welcome Marziapie
M - Thank you
Subscribe to Daniel7689
*awkward silence*
M - Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas
P - Merry Christmas everyone!
MERRRY CHRISTMAS EVERYONE!
M - What- what we're gonna play today?
P - Oh I found the best game I could possibly find cuz Christmas is a special day
M - Mmm
P - We need to play the best game, POSSIBLE.
P - I've been saving this game for years.
M - Wow!
P - Literally.
P - 2012 is back cuz we're playing SLENDERMAN'S SHADOW!
M - WHAAAT?
P - You can have the option to Play or Run Away. What do you choose?
M - PLAY!
P - Oh okay. Slenderman's Shadow!
M - Yeah!
P - It could be anythi- Oh my God!
P - I think it's behind me -OH- it's just Danny Devito.
P - D-*giggles* Danny you scared us.
P - Look at that face
P - He's like GOTCHA!...Got-em..
M - Is there anything Christmas related?
P - Oh yeah, this is the Christmas special
P - Dan and Phil played it and I did not rip this idea off from them.
M - But I haven't seen it so does *INAUDIBLE*
P - I don't watch them either! *roasted*
P - Collect all 8 presents.
M - How do I move?
P - I don't know, probably WASD, yeh there you go
P - I'll do the looking.
M - And I do the moving?
P - You do the walking
P - I like the music
P - Good choice of music, game
P - Alright let's go in here
P - Wow I'm so in festive Christmas mood right now *gr8 English dere m8*
M - So are we looking for the notes?
P - Ye- no presents
P - 8 presents
*pewds n marzia jammin out*
*jamming out intensifies*
*pewds be laughing while marzia starts dancin*
P - HEY THERE"S A (Pewds forgets the word for a second) SNOWMAN
P - This music is amAAAAZINGG
P - *sings* in a one-horse open sleigh
P - over hills we-
P - (realises he doesn't know lyrics) MARZIA TAKE IT OVER
P - I'll DANCE!
M - Wat? o.o
*Marzia completely disregards what felix says and starts dancing too*
M - I'm walking! *looks like yer dancin*
*Marzia laughs*
M - Come on! HELPME!
P - or you can- okay
M - How many gifts are we looking for?
P - EIGHT
P - We need EIGHT
P - You gotta go faster
P - Okay I'm not finding any presents
P - Try over here
P - I already hate the music (says the one who was jamming out to it a few seconds ago)
*sees present in the distance*
P - oh OHOH
P - WE FOUND IT
P - WE FOUND ONE
P - GOT IT
M - OH!
P - I think the bass improved a little bit (starts jamming out to music again)
P - Oh it did!
P - Oh my god (Pewds can't believe he likes this music)
P - Just try to focus on the happy music Marzia, we can do this!
*zooms in on marzia*
P - (Pewds triesto make up a cool name) Slanta Cau-Slan- Slanter is coming
*a for effort*
P - I don't know where to go (OH RLy?) that's the problem
*le silence*
*idk what they're saying*
P - ooOOOH HE WAS-
M & P - sAAAANTAAAAAAAAA
M - AND HE'S RANDOMLY STANDING
P - AND IT'S NOT A GOOD THING
*in a Texan accent?*
M - Santa's after us!
P - Where is he? I'm not-
-scared of Santa
*dancin to le music*
*keep on a-dancin*
*o rip you're not green pewdiepie*
*sure you're not scared?*
P - This isn't- I hate this game
*silence*
P - omg
M - OHHHH
*le static (speaks my name)*
P - OH what's happening? nO!
M - Saaaantaaaaa
Santa - HO HO HO HO HO HO
*hey dere Santy Claus*
...
P - nnnnOOOOOOOOOOOOOH MY GOD that was so scary
*le sarcasm is strong with this one*
M - Wait, there wasn't *inaudible* finish?
*Danny Devito intensifies*
M - bwEEEEEHHHHHHHHHH
*woah Marzia dat was a real jumpscare*
M - *cute giggle*
P - *tf?*
P - I guess not.
P - I guess...
*Danny Devito falls*
P - DANNY.
P - What are you, tryin' ta hit on ma gurl, Danny? What da hell?
*as Danny Devito*
M - Yeah I'm hitting her
*le giggle*
*as Danny Devito*
P - She makes my knees weak *aRMS ARE HEAVY*
...
M - Danny-
*falls*
*still as Danny Devito*
P - AAH CAN'T HE- I'M- AH, SHE TOUCHED ME!
P - Kay, let's just- this is-
M - Alright, I'll hold him, I'll hold him.
P - You'll hold Danny?
M - My best friend.
P - *jealousy maybe?* Okay, how about, uh, we take turns, how 'bout dat?
M - Mmm
P - Okay
M - How about I...move. With the mouse.
*Marzia controls le mouse*
P - OMG I'm having a seizure
P - Don't do that
M - *laughs*
P - Please, I feel sick.
P - You lo-
M - OMG Danny
M - Can you get off me?
*jealous much Pewds?*
P - DANNY! Get off ma gurl!
P - I wanna die, please kill me... *same*
P - ...Merry Christmas, to all da bros :D
M - *jams slowly towards Pewds*
P - We have to beat this g-
M - *jams more*
P - We have to-
M - It's not my fault, it's the music- it's like that.
*le loud gasp*
*sees present*
P - yEEEEEEES
M - We did it!
P - Okay, let's pick it up-
P - St- stop stop stop stop stop
*magical whoosh*
P - Got it
P - Okay we got 'em
M - GOT 'EM
P - GOOOOOOOT 'EMMM
P - Alright keep look-
*le gasp*
P - OH go go go. Straight. Shit.
*sees present*
P - Oh, there.
*magical whoosh*
P - GOT 'EM
M -WE GOT IT!
P - WOAH
P - What was that?
P - Santa? Santa?
P - Santa was that you Santa?
M - We're technically stealing gifts, so I wouldn't-
*ooh good point*
P - No, we're tak- it's our gift, it's our gift dammit!
*nice save*
P - omg
Santa - mEEERRY CHRISTMAS
M - *gets sp00ked*
P - WOAH
P - You got a little spooked out dere?
S - HO HO HO HO HO HO HO
*Marzia getting spooked replayed*
P - *imitating Marzia* mmERRY Chri-
M - You got scared because I got scared.
M - You were like- *imitates Pewds*
*laughs*
P - Like, what's wrong with you?
P - You got spa- scared by a scary-
M - Okay
P - Scary game.
M - I thought I would see him, it was just like-
P - We are so bad at this game.
*moves Danny*
P - HEY!
M - What?
P - WHAT ARE YOU DOING WITH DANNY
M - I made him stay straight...
*le jealousy look*
M - Look!
P - Fine.
M - It wasn't that difficult.
M - You just don't know how to handle a man *laughs*
*wtf*
P - Oookay...
P - He's so creepy in the back, look at that.
M - What?
P - He's right between us...
*le gasp*
P - YEAH! 2 out of 8
M - Ye boiii
P - C'mon gurl we can do this!
M - *growls*
P - We can-
P - There's so many damn houses
M - Oh! Oh!
P - There's a tiny lil gift!
M - Yeah!
*static*
P - Oh! Take it and go!
M - GET IT!
S - mEERRYY CHRISTMAS!
M - Nooooooooooooo
P - MOTHERFUCKER CHRISTMAS MA-
P - We don't even see him.
M - *wtf gesture*
P  - *wtf gesture*
P - This game sucks.
P - Let's switch to another one...:D
*sneaky sneaky Marzia*
P - What, are you doing right now...
*the stroking of the face*
P - Thank you- this is Danny Devito's arms around me *laughs* it looks like it!
*zooms in on Danny*
P - Oh- Danny- DANNY NOO!
*the choking of the Pewds*
M - Wh- what is it?
P - This is the scariest horror Christmas game.
M - Yeah
P - On YouTube
M - Mmm
P - Take a-
M - What is it? Is it Krampus?
P - It's- yeah...
M - It feels- I feel weird getting so close to this screen.
M - Oh
*ticking*
P - Wow
M - *laughs*
P - It's like watching a professional.
P - Look at that tree it looks so great.
M - What do I have to do?
P - I don't know.
P - This looks awful. I mean-
*loud noise*
P - OH!
M - *laughs*
M - Don't scare me like that!
P - *laughs*
M - I told you!
P - What just happened?
*weird tinkly music begins playing*
P - What is this game?
*Santa Claus is Coming to Town starts playing*
P - This is soo baad
P - Santa Claus is coming, Marzia!
*Pewds starts singing along*
P - Oh god, we're dead. We're so dead Marzia.
*WTAF IS THAT*
P - OHHHH MAAAAAAAA GAAAAAAAAAWD
M - Is that Santa? That looks like a troll!
*shame*
P - 10/10
P - Lock the door.
M - I mean it didn't scare me
? - HO HO HO HO HO MERR-
M - It didn't even-
P - Just greaat...
P - Just fantastic
M - BLUURRRP
M - *hair flick*
P - It's one of those videos isn't it? *laughs*
P - You re-
M - I need to pump up ma hair!
P - Are you ready?
M - Now I'm ready!
P - Are you ready Marzia?
M - Yee!
P - omg I hate this
P - Dashing through the snow, and I wanna die-
P - ouhhhhhhhhHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
M - What if the snowman is actually Santa Claus? Ooh-
P - WHAT IF THE SNOWMAN IS ACTUALLY SANTA CLAUS?!
*the gasp of the gift*
P - GO
M - Did he pu- did he put it up there?
P  - We're- yeah- OH
P - OH NO OH (times infinity)
M - RUN RUN RUN (also times infinity)
P - OH MA GAWD HE'S COMING!
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
P - Santa Claus-
S - mmEERRRY CHRISTMAS
M&P - *complaints*
P - FUCK YOU SANTA, I HATE YOU
P - But do give me some presents-
M - You've been naughty-
P - Coz I've been a very good boi ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )
P - AGAIN!
P - Okay, you want me to do it?
P - Don't take off my clothes
*um Marzia?*
P - You want the fangirls?
*omg*
P - Is that what you- thank you.
P - I'll show you how it's done, Marzia, I'll do it for you!
M - Yeah you show me!
M - Then I'll play without you!
P - Okay, fine
*sneaky Marzia rubs his nipple*
P - omg don't rub my nipple. This is weird, this is weird *laughs*
P - *weird sigh*
M - *jams to music*
P - Are you dancing in the background?
P - I don't have time to look
P - There's a present right dere.
*magical whoosh*
P - YEAH!
*the dance of Danny Devito*
P - So sh-
P - Why do we- THERE'S A PRESENT!
P - Thank you Danny Devito, it's helping!
*as Danny Devito*
M - No problem man!
P - I don't like the vo- uh  I mean what is that voice you gave Danny?
P - OH!
*magical whoosh*
P - 3
P - See what happens when I don't play with you?
*oof man*
P - I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding don't hurt me
M - See you, byeee!
P - No don't leave me Marzia, I need you Marzia I'm kidding!
P - I need you- it was Danny that did it all along!
P - 4
*magical whoosh*
M - You think you're so good huh?
P - I- omg, he's coming Marzia.
M - You're such a little chicken!
P - *jumps*
P - Oh ma gawd!
*as Danny Devito*
P - Hey how's it going, it's Danny Devito and Marzia
P as Danny - You're doing so good Marzia
M - SHH
P - Amen
M  -What if I win this game?
P as Danny - *sneak*
*close your eyes for this part ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° )*
M - Ooh that feels nice
P as Danny - Ya like dat Marzia?
M - Ya
M - AAH!
M - ONE!
P from le floor - *inaudible*
M - How do I pick it up?
P - *rises from the dead* whAT?
M - Dat's right!
P - Wait, you actually got by yourself?
M - YEAh!
M - Shishidrr
P - What did you say?
M - Shishidrr!
M - It means "stop trying to make me lose, I'm doing great without you"!
*static*
M - OHH!
M - Still doing great
P - Yeah? You're doing great?  You're feeling good?
M - Ye-
S - mmMERRRY CHHRISTMASSS
M -UGH!
S - HO HO HO HO HO
*le hug*
M - I was so focused!
P - I've never seen you get jumpscared, it's so funny XD
*both laugh*
P - Think we have to end it there, before-
M - On a high note-
P - There's too much- yeah there was
P - It doesn't get better than that!
*enter cardboard PewDiePie*
P - ALRIGHT, THANK YOU- CLAP IT OU- MERRY- MERRY CHRISTMAS TO EVERYONE WE HOPE-
M - Aren't you gonna show Slippy?
*that damn toad*
P - Why?
M - He has to say "Merry Christmas"!
P - M'kay...
P - Merry Christmas from all of us!
M - Yeah
P - And Slippy- Wait Slippy wants to say?
*as Slippy*
P - Merry Christmas!
P as Slippy - And Happy New Year
P - Thank you Marzia for coming on and, uh-
M - No problem!
P - We're gonna be in Sweden for Christmas, celebrating Christmas so-
M - Mmm!
P - We hope you enjoy this video meanwhile-
M - Sorry, if there's no snow I'm gonna be very disappointed.
P - *oh shit*
M - But yeah, hope you enjoyed!
P - And as always...
BROFISTTTTT
P - Actually, y'know what we do now?
P - CHECK OUT THIS VIDEO! OH MY GOD LOOK AT THAT VIDEO! CLICK ON IT RIGHT NOW!
M - Am I on the video-
P - You are on the video
P - Now you're- dere ya go, click it!
P - And we'll s- have fun and click on that-
M - Why are you-
P - WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOW!!!!!!
Merry Christmas to all of the fans and pewds from the subtitle writers! :D